well in Sri Lanka Security forces have
cleared the main protest camp in the
capital Colombo it was the base of
anti-government protests for over three
months the overnight raid came just
hours before demonstrators were due to
leave voluntarily
they are likely to be angered by the
swearing-in of new prime minister Dinesh
gunawadna he's a close Ally of ousted
president gotabaya rakapaksa who was
forced to leave office amid public rage
about Sri Lanka's severe economic crisis
allow South Asia bureau chief Amrita
Cheema is in Colombo covering events
there for us she was outside the
presidential Palace earlier where that
camp was cleared I asked her for more
details about the raid
Anthony we had a very dramatic uh night
here in the heart of Colombo I'm
standing in front of the presidential
Secretariat where I've been reporting
for the past week and this was a hub of
protests in fact it was the last Bastion
of protests inside a government property
protesters had gone in in the entrance
of this uh building and they were holed
up there and were protesting but then in
the dark night at late at night suddenly
we had hundreds of soldiers and police
Commandos swarm around this area there
was armored personnel carriers deployed
there then soldiers came in here and
what they did was they immediately
cleared up these protests there moved
the people out and then this is a
situation that we have now barricades
have been set up police officers and the
Army have been deployed on the other
side of the barricades is the largest
protest Camp the go gota Gama Camp
that's also been cleared apparently at
least the media says some dozens of
people were injured at least nine people
were arrested and detained and those
some people who resisted arrest were
roughed up in fact even journalists were
roughed up one of our colleagues from
the BBC was also hit some of the injured
are now in hospital we're also hearing
some reports that a few of the
protesters are still stranded in the
camp Below in this Secretariat yesterday
we showed you signs like run I'll go
home and people with Sri Lankan flags
and the atmosphere was quite relaxed but
all that has gone no Flags here no
people here we just spoke to a couple of
uh activists who were here and they say
that some protesters are stranded behind
at that camp and they were trying to get
food to them but these men here said no
way you're not allowed to go through so
they just had to back off so after all
of that action you've described Amrita
the calm is this a temporary calm or is
this the new government back in full
control of the situation
well looking at these scenes Anthony it
looks like the government is in control
as for calm well we didn't see any
outrage on the streets of Sri Lanka uh
or at least in the capital Colombo this
week last week we saw extraordinary
scenes here when there were hundreds and
thousands of people protesting but this
week it's been relatively subdued the
protests but whether this will last
remains to be seen because I think
protesters will see this Hardline action
by the government perhaps it's
provocative and that may force them to
come out on the streets again now the
Sri Lankan Bar Association was outraged
by what happened in the early hours of
the morning they condemned the
disproportionate use of force which they
said against peaceful protesters
describing it as Despicable they try to
mediate but in fact two of their lawyers
were arrested that's what they say and
then the Human Rights Commission was
also here trying to negotiate mediate
with the Army and saying let these
people go because there were reports as
you mentioned that they were voluntarily
going to leave this evening but as we
saw the government chose to take a
Hardline action against them
and Rita quickly before we go what is
the new president's plan to ease Sri
Lanka's economic crisis
what he's done uh Anthony firstly is
he's sworn in an interim cabinet he's
also appointed a new prime minister as
you mentioned and the prime ministers
from the ruling party so that will anger
protesters even more he is going to soon
be starting talks with International
donors and lenders like the IMF and he's
due to announce some measures to give
relief to the people who've been
suffering so much in the past three
months
I'm Rita Chima in the Sri Lankan Capital
Colombo thank you so much